[Applause]
[Music]
i'm giving you one minute and i'll show
you how bigtable can help you analyze
large workloads
cloud bigtable is a fully managed
scalable
nosql database for large analytical and
operational workloads
it is designed as a sparsely populated
table that can
scale to billions of rows and thousands
of columns
enabling you to store terabytes or even
petabytes of data
bigtable is a key value store that
supports high read and write throughput
at low latency supporting millions of
requests per second
need to increase queries per second just
add more bigtable nodes
it is an ideal data source for mapreduce
style operations
and integrates easily with existing big
data tools like hadoop
dataflow and dataproc to help you get
started quickly
it also supports open source hbase api
standard
ready to set up bigtable get started by
designing the schema
planning out queries and designing a row
key
once finalized create a bigtable
instance using this
gcloud command cloud console or the api
in bigtable you write data once and it
automatically replicates where needed
with eventual consistency
giving you control for high availability
and isolation of read and write
workloads
bigtable powers google products used by
billions
such as search and maps and you can use
it to store and query your data too
including time series marketing and
financial data
so next time you're looking to analyze
large workloads
take a minute to look at bigtable to
learn more
check out cloud.google.com bigtable